do you want no one makes an idea true
then everybody watch teen show that
didn't show miss malotte hamdulillah
Salaam alaikum peace be with you imma to
your host you are watching addition when
we come back we're going to be talking
to Ibrahim Sheikh Ibrahim is a Dan he
has his own section at the Dean show
calm you can go back to see who he is
his biography and all the past shows
that we've done with him we're going to
talk to him today about patience many of
us need it we lack it sometimes we
forget that this is one of the elements
that is so important in Islam to be
patient patiently staying away from the
evil patiently be doing all the good
that the craters told us to do so we're
going to get some more advice some
encouragement to be patient we'll be
right back here on the dijo a la there's
only one word how mad is his messenger
Allah
ah ha there's only one but Jesus was his
messenger Allah know why I did that
maybe it maybe it's just to break the
ice Salaam alaikum he's be with you you
too greeting of all the prophets isn't
it right they all taught pure monotheism
isn't it correct is this a lie we
telling the truth that's that's for sure
the message has been the same since the
beginning worship the crater not his
creation I'm just learned i'm a student
tell me some more didn't all the
messengers they talk don't worship God's
creation a man or a woman but worship
the Creator man and woman isn't this
true it's true unless the first
obligation on every human being every
human being known by native about the
creator of the heavens and the earth
because we see the favours of the
creator of the heavens and the earth
around us that's why people need the
messengers for them to call them to
worship the one that they believe in the
one that provides with them the one that
creates things with them they need to
turn to him alone that's how a simple
that it is without the manipulation of
other human beings otherwise it doesn't
make sense that it's one God but then
more than one religion doesn't make
sense it's only one religion the
religion of submission to the creator of
heavens and the earth no difference
between white or black somewhat in the
North or the South were all human beings
from one and that is Adam lost planet
Allah created him send them on the face
of earth to fulfill this purpose this
noble purpose to be a worshiper servant
of the creator of the heavens in you
that's simple one God worship that God
alone and not what he created and he sat
down a comprehensive message for us that
we need to live by the Quran which the
verbatim word of God and the example of
the last and final messenger sent to
mankind so we don't have to be you know
bumping into this and that trying to
figure thing I was getting confused loss
is there we just have to learn it and
sit with people such as yourself who can
teach us that's why we got you here we
want to talk about patience God Almighty
he commands us in the Quran to do so
many wonderful things to strive for
paradise death is approaching we got to
get ready we got it
by action talk is cheap that we love God
because he loves us has given us so much
so now he's told us to implement certain
things that if only the human being uses
his mind he'll see there's so much
wisdom behind this and you get a good
feeling doing what God wants to do but
now my question is my question is shake
time is going sometimes when you look
back seems like time pass by went by
quick when you're in a moment some
people you know just getting up in the
morning it's tough it's like I've done
it like a thousand times by now you know
what I mean you might get stale in it we
need some encouragement to be patient
with the prayer and the maguann from
there to be patient with the orders of
Allah spano dalawa need to seek help
from him and as I mentioned before every
human being they seek some form of
pieces if a person knows that if he
wakes up in the morning at three o'clock
in the morning for a job that would pay
him a million dollar a month I don't
think anybody would say I would just
sleep and I would go late or quit the
day everybody would go there on it they
would spend the whole night being awake
they would have to go why because there
is no the certainty and the reality of
the million dollar but for the believers
when they received a message from the
creator of the heavens and the earth and
when the prophets peace be upon him he
said in the authentic hadith if people
knows the reward in nasha prayers and
then fed repair the early morning prayer
they would come to it even if they have
to crawl if we see the unseen and what
is being prepared for the person people
would even have to crawl in their faces
to get to the houses of a lot to
establish the prayers we don't need to
see that with our own eyes we already
see that from the worship from the
revelation from Allah span all time we
already see it we said we bear witness
bearing witness meaning that I saw with
my own eyes that there is no one worthy
of worship except Allah saw hinata
hannah and that prophet muhammad is the
final messenger if wee-bey witness such
a way that means we bear witness than
anything that is being said so we need
to be patient to do that and one
statement and i think i remember i
mentioned that before it's a beautiful
statement that we need to always
remember that it now claim one of the
scholars of the religion he said if we
were ordered if muslims were ordered to
push a mountain from its place if this
was the order of Allah of course this is
not
but if this was the order from Allah the
most high to push a mountain from its
place if you put your trust in Allah you
push it Paula so if Allah subhana Allah
ordered us to be patient to do the
orders of Allah to stay away from sins
put your trust in Allah that he would
never let you down you will be able to
do it it's in the nature of the human
being now people they commit some
hideous acts people will murder people
we know that in Islam you cannot hurt
innocent women children or you know
murder is one of the things that now on
a day of judgement one of the first
things a person will be accountable is
it so people because of lack of patience
they might go kill somebody because of a
lack of patience they might go commit
some kind of injustice towards somebody
oppress somebody they might end up
uttering curse words profanity getting
divorced talk to us about some practical
examples maybe you've how you probably
get a lot of emails and people like once
they do it now they realize they calm
down and they're like oh man I shouldn't
have done that but what can they do when
you get in that fit of rage what do you
do to like is it's not is that is that
just is it bad to feel the rage is that
normal or then how do you control it
take a deep breath give us some examples
so you don't commit bad things hideous
things evil things then you like man I
wish I didn't do that it's too late it's
a very important point because a lot of
the most high he meant it in the Quran
that too and he mention about the
characteristics of the believers one of
the characteristics will carefully mean
alive those who suppress their anger
suppressant suppress don't let it out
that's right and that means that whoever
does not get angry he is like and
forgive me for the expression like a
donkey as he managed a fairy he said
here right we all get angry this is in
the midst of the human being but that's
nothing bad you should feel guilty about
you don't see yourself getting angry
that means something wrong with you okay
so you have to get angry but the point
is how to deal with you inc ah that's
the key question do you lose it and you
act according to your desire and your
anger or you use your mind and you know
that Allah wants something from you when
you're angry and that's why the steps of
dealing with one selves when we're angry
it's there also in the Koran and then
this one now the prophets are second
solemn when he saw two men arguing with
each other to the extent of which one
his face became red and his veins became
clear that means he's angry and when a
person in that state he does not know
what he's doing yeah the prophet saw
shall have said I know something if he
said it that would go away from him and
what is it I older belong in astrology I
seek refuge in Allah from the Shaitan
redeemed accursed devil because he is
the one that blow into the person into
that to make him that fierce fire wooden
with the anger so we need to seek refuge
but we need not to say to our tongue
only we need to sincerely see it would
say to their own hearts that returning
to Allah because he is the only one that
can helps us in that state not ourselves
we need to seek refuge in him from the
cursed Shaytan if a person is standing
is to sit down as the Prophet peace be
upon him said if you're sitting down an
angry lay down and that would show those
who submit themselves to the Prophet to
Allah subhanAllah de through the orders
of the Prophet SAW salem and those who
choose to follow their desires so these
are practical steps physical steps that
nobody should say I I cannot do it no
you can do it you can't lay down and you
can't sit down and and you can say our
global language toronto's you but the
real point is it's not just the words
it's the whole lifestyle that we have if
a person is rubidium to Allah praying
the five daily prayers practicing the
patience to fulfill the orders of Allah
practicing patience to be away from sins
I think the easiest part is that part
that you're talking about and one of the
major issues and maybe this is something
that needs to be addressed in more
details that we get so many of the
questions and the issues that people
regret so much it's not about killing or
so necessarily but about divorce people
divorce a man divorces his wife because
of the moment of anger this is not what
a las panel tana once almost goes back
to patient triangles back to patients
and then he would regret I didn't intend
to divorce her and they would divorce
three times and as we know this is not a
joke if a person say the words of the
worst three times on his wife that's it
the marriage is over she they cannot go
back together unless you get married to
someone else with the intentions that
this is an everlasting marriage and then
if it happened
they divorced then they can go back
together so people would come and they
were trying to find a way out to say I
was angry I was this I was that so that
they would you know cancel this divorce
a disaster why because people are
practicing this great act of worship and
that is sub patients Almanac October of
Dalaran he said something is amazing he
said we lived the best of our life when
we were pieces this was one of the
Companions of life the kind of messenger
so the best times when we were patient
when we were practicing it let's cut out
with that would be right back with more
here on the D show he is born about 60
years ago in former Yugoslavia today's
Vasya after Second World War and imagine
today you have one child feel too much
it's important that we realize that
Islam is a gift so we believe that in
the teachings of Jesus what is left
there is truth in a minha he's the
priest but the truth has been mixed up
with paganism and with nature worship
and so Islam has given you a pure
straightforward way of approaching
monotheism back here on the Dean show
we're talking about patience the
importance of patients we lose it we
it's okay to you get like red in the
face but you gotta like a lot of times
they say let it out scream maybe throw
something you don't we don't do that do
we fight we don't do that okay there are
a lot of people they take and exit life
gets difficult with family with friends
and we've had people run their car into
a river commit suicide someone jumps off
the bridge drinks Drano and dies killed
kills themselves does this go back to
not having patience and committing
something that is totally foreign to
Islam there's no exit way or committing
yourself suicide this is not for
committed definitely it's not
permissible why because this life is a
trust that a lot of the most i entrusted
us with it and it's a favor from the
most high soprano time but when people
have deficiencies in there amen in their
belief and their certainty in the
rewards from the creator of heavens and
the earth then the deficiencies comes in
place in all of their life so
we talk about patience when a person
have deficiency in patients it's because
of the deficiency in the II Men in the
belief as sin might affect one's
patience that we don't see the
relationship between one or the other
that's why we need to constantly turn to
the creator of heavens and the earth and
be obedient to him and ask him for all
our needs and to be physically patient
in fulfilling the orders of Allah one of
which is there is no exit to one's
problems except from the creator of
devon's anyway so you can't go jump off
a bridge you can't give you those
patient you have to witness the wisdom
of Allah why this is happening to you it
happens from the most twice and the most
merciful despite is nothing and it will
end anyway when a person dies first and
now on the grave even if he was the most
rich man on the face of earth he would
wish to come back on the face of earth
and be in poverty and being whatever
calamities there is because now he
realized the importance of this life to
use it for the sake of allah so a person
should never be ungrateful to a las
panel Tala that he wants to lose his
life and this is against to what a las
panel tyla odors in the quran and
there's another prophet saw said instead
patients would bring joy and that's why
we have to submit if a person submit
himself and patiently fulfill the orders
of allah and again and again you need to
say he would never feel the loss and
that's why the prophets are de la risa
lemme said amazing is the affairs of the
believers if something good happens to
them they're grateful to allah if
something bad happens to them there are
priests and they're seeking the woods in
both ways you are slave you are not free
to do whatever you want to a servant of
Allah sierra nevada from the creator of
the heavens inuit something good happy a
person is happy something bad happens is
patient and is seeking the order for
mystery we are when they say monogamous
we are as those who have submitted to
the one god those who are truly
monogamous meaning that we are the ones
who don't go have girlfriends we don't
commit adultery because we know as the
craters told us to do things the right
way do it in marriage and you see
society people go out and they say they
push this idea of one husband one wife
but what happens is they got 15
different mistresses on the sides we
know how that goes presidents alike and
politicians and all the other people but
now the question is arising so
just to kind of give an intro to the
next question the sisters asking because
we know that look if there's an avenue
there if a gentleman almost some you
know he's got as they say if you want to
drink the milk you gotta buy the cow you
know there's no test driving here so the
sisters saying she said how can I be
patient you know what I mean with the co
wife she went and got a second wife and
now she's asking some invite is there a
great reward on this for the sister
whose patient in this circumstance for
the sisters there in that state we need
to witness also the wisdom of Allah
spinal tap and we have to separate the
feelings from the wisdom of Allah
subhana Allah that looks into more than
just personal feelings there are so much
benefits behind the orders of Allah span
of the benefits for societies and again
in Islam it's not permissible to commit
adultery it's not permissible to commit
these sins so if there are women they
have to get married for them to fulfill
their desires and the same thing for men
so what happens if there are more women
than men and this is from the reality of
the Metis or even as you said a person
you know wanting to get married to
another or second and so on this is
something that Allah spano talent remits
out of the reality of the human beings
so the point is everybody all of us on
the face of earth we have some forms of
tests and trials in our life some people
lose the legs some people lose their
eyes some people they died some people
things like this and one of which for a
wife to have a cool wife this is one of
the trials in life if this is the only
thing from the husband the feeling of
jealousy in the heart of the first wife
or the second wife that means he
successfully being just between both of
them or been more if this is the only
thing why because the prophet saw said I
lost my lord Allah ordered us to be just
and if a person is not just he will come
on the day of judgment with one shoulder
higher than the others because he was
not just with his wife it's a
responsibility is not just about
fulfilling the desires it's another
whole of establishing a home structure
with the responsibility with children
taking care of them it's an act of
worship that we have to be aware of so
for the system this happens to her some
they would just want a divorce we need
they need to be patient and the brother
also need to be patiently dealing with
his wife's and if she gets angry with
him he should not say this is the order
of a lawyer undermining the order of
Allah no he need to be patient with her
and you need to be kind with her because
this is a natural thing in the human
being and for her to be patient and
knowing that this is the order of Allah
there's definitely AI wisdom behind it
otherwise the second wife wouldn't agree
to be a second one so there's a wisdom
behind it because it's from the most
high the most merciful of Hannah Montana
so by practicing this type of patience
and whenever the pain and the heart
comes in place if she seeks the reward
from Allah subhana Allah was regarding
to that pain it would change to be
something better definitely and the
woods are unlimited as we heard when it
comes to matters of the he left but as
long as nobody would abuse one another
and use tricks and manipulation to
fulfill one's desires and not to fulfill
the orders of Allah spaniel so for this
particular case before we go on this is
one of the greatest rewards as was
holding is this jealousy in this
situation for the woman definitely and
at the same time it will have to appear
this is in her nature yeah so it's the
order from Allah spinel tyla to the
husband to be patient if she shows the
signs of the jealousy then he has to be
patiently respecting them yeah and not
to say how can he do that and not
understanding the nature of his wife
this is against what the prophets are
selling himself is it and the wives are
the prophets are selling themselves they
would show this jealousy but if they are
seldom speaks but if they say now look
you know we're not them that you're here
excuse and they say well we're not like
them they were at a different level with
you guys this is never an excuse because
it's the same thing when I lost panel
Tyler says in the Quran now for the
candela comfy Rasool a showtune hisana
demon can I all dual-audio minetta that
indeed in the prophets are seldom you
have the best example so if a person
would say I'm not like the prophets
asylum of course would not like the
prophet saw said but a lot of panel data
ordered us to imitate him in everything
of his affairs in his speech in his
actions and everything that he did and a
lost panel Tyler made the prophets are
selling married to his wife's for the
Muslim woman in our ummah to imitate
them because they were the best women
ever brought to
so it's an order from Allah spano data
for us to follow their way with goodness
and if we are patiently wanting the
pleasure of Allah sky montana and i'm
saying that and then there's no doubt
about it truthfully whoever see leave
something for the sake of allah lost
penetrata would replace it by something
better and this is what the prophets are
silent so having a healthy argument the
woman gets jealous you said that you
know don't get upset about it but is
their perimeters where you don't go out
of bounds saying things curse words
curse an individual you know doing
things that are unhealthy unproductive
so you can have an argument but is there
some perimeters we don't go out like
foul lines right it's in both sides when
people get into arguments on the
Shaitaan comes in between he wants to
make one side hurts the other one so
much with words words hurt sometimes
more than physical hurt that from years
old the husband for example would see a
word to hurt his wife you know with the
word and then she would respond with
something else and then it goes on till
we know that what happens and sometimes
the worst happens or hitting physically
hitting and all of that is not
permissible whatsoever it's not
acceptable say in a bad word saying or
hitting physically this is not
permissible this is a major sin and for
the worse to occur just out of anger or
things of that nature this is all the
works of Chevron yeah so knowing this is
one thing to have the knowledge that
this is something that is meant for us
by the sheriff on to do so and he's our
enemy so we stay away from that and to
seek the help from a las panel trial and
again the wife should be patiently
suppressing her jealousy and turning to
a low not seen suppressing it and then
cause herself to be sick no we have the
best way to complain and to increase our
amend by turning to the creator of the
heavens and the earth and asking him
sincerely to reward them to give
patients and to make the Christian
pleased and so on and if she slips away
it is her right this is a very important
point it is her right if she slips away
that her husband is patiently treating
her with patience because he's in charge
so if she is saying things and hurting
him with words and screaming and things
like that he can remind her of a las
panel Tyler patiently sometimes people
would start doing this but then once she
attacked him personally
then he forgets all about the different
mannerism and patience and then he
attacked it hey texture also which is
all wrong lots of Hannah Tyler said in
the Quran that among your wives and your
children you might have them as enemies
to you if they order you to commit sins
and this will be a lost fan of that even
that what a las manos had a tired i said
about what to do with them he said we
interact with us for what a few if you
pardon if you forgive then this is
better for you and all spinal Tala is
the most forgiving let's take a break
and be right back with more on the D
show no problem you can take my daughter
to dinner you and my daughter and me do
you ever tell you something it's
naturally just idea not creating it and
he created us to have a good time you
should have a good time one without
wives though Islam is the fastest
growing religion in the world and most
of the converts are women not men they
see that the rules of Islam instead of
constraining it the rule set them free
in one I am not afraid to stand alone if
a lot about this i am not afraid to
stand alone i am not afraid to stand
alone if a las bombas I am Not Afraid
I am NOT alone I am not afraid to step
back here on the Dean show and we're
discussing patients so we just asked the
question about the co wife and this is a
big test but is it true that Allah the
Creator he won't put a burden on someone
that you can't bear there's nothing or
ever a test that you can't handle as
correct and this is something that at
the end of the little vaca a las paneled
a dimension bed and accepted that from
the Companions of the law annum and the
OMA and the nation of the Prophet SAW
Salem that there is no order of a lost
panel data that is over the capacity of
the human being we have to endure
patience and patience a person would say
has limits to it and according to the
orders of Allah nothing of the orders of
a lot that is over the limits of the
human beings and again things are looked
at into a into the bigger picture than
just our personal desire and benefits we
have to look into the benefit of the
whole Ummah and the community of the
Muslims and be patiently doing things
that's why being generous sometimes you
have to be generous with your time you
have to give you time you want to sleep
you want to relax but you know that
there's a duty out there that you need
to help human beings into have the
Muslims and so on so you give that for
the sake of Allah soprano tada and so
the same thing a person or a wife has
her husband she can be generous with
that regard for the sake of Allah span
of time but again we need to do that
humbly according to the orders of Allah
not just a matter of desire and that's
it it's a matter of establishing the
religion of allah islam with its perfect
way of life so does it help have in your
heart always attached to the bigger
scheme of things jenna paradise and
trying to not just focus on yourself
focus on helping and getting like you
said generosity and not just focusing on
you know like you're going to be in this
world forever you know you can die
tomorrow and paradise is there so you
know this will help kind of like if
you're losing your mind for a moment you
feel like
my god I can't take it oh and your head
spinning you got pop some xanax or
something no you can take it just relax
right think about the bigger scheme of
things and change the change your whole
entire life yeah you cannot be patient
to the one thing and then other things
you're not being paid great example okay
so you have the patience for something
else you can have the patience you seek
the patients and all of your affairs if
you really practicing patience at all
levels if we change our whole entire
life to be true servants of Allah
sanatana that's why when i said sins
effects our ability to be patient if
we're not patiently away from certain
sins that means we'll have deficiencies
and other levels of patience when we
needed too much so we have to adopt the
whole religion understand and another
thing for the for the brothers also we
need to understand that when the ax man
is not in the proper level don't expect
sacrifices so we need to build our homes
based on the e men and the faith and
increasing it that's the foundation
that's the condition if there are sins
in the home if there are sins committed
by the brother or by the wife or in the
household they don't expect that in that
one particular issue you want your wife
to be a super wife and to be of that
secant artery woods when you're not seek
andheri would someone lost pilot ever
being patiently obedient to Allah span
of time and all of our fears you gotta
holistically heritage taken all of it
all of it need to change our life to be
all according to what Allah span of
hannah wants from us and not to pick and
choose with regarding to what makes us
feel good or our design not a buffet now
that's right yeah he can't just take
what's good for you and convenient and
other things i'll leave that away that's
why patients is bitten that means you
but it doesn't feel good in the
beginning yeah you don't want to do it
basically but you're doing it because
you have a mind and you read in the
Quran and this one of the prophets or
sell any good to know that this is what
a las pilot ally wants from you so
you're a human being you decide for
yourself this is what is good for me I'm
going to do it and then you go through
the struggle and then it becomes you
norm but it doesn't happen overnight and
that's why the bitterness of patients we
have to taste it and we seek the help
from Allah spano tyla that we're not
doing that for our own desires we're
doing that for the sake of the creator
of the heavens in eternal last question
and closing comments for because this is
a vast topic so much to cover so little
time
patients with the kids patients with
your husband patients with your wife
sometimes the husband or wife nagging
about this thousand things to do you
can't get to everything just leave me
alone and so many things going on in the
world you're going here and there
closing comments and suggestions for
these other practical situations all of
these situations the way to do it the
right way is that we need to be obedient
to Allah spinal tap in our religion
there is etiquette for everything the
prophets are salamone said hi Rock'em
Sock'em Liliana haruka me Ali the best
among you at the best to his family and
I'm the best to my family this is the
order of Allah subhana Allah so we need
to learn what are the etiquettes or
relationships together the real
mannerism of the person shows to those
who are closest to him that's why for my
mannerism you don't know the real
mannerism that I have my wife knows it
very well and the same thing for
everybody so that's why we need to this
is the field of patients that if we work
on ourselves and an hour in our homes to
be the most perfect human beings in
mannerism and patience and everything
then you don't have to worry too much
about what you do outside the house
because this is the real challenge when
a person living with people closely but
how to do that we need to learn the
sooner the way of the Prophet SAW cells
in really relating to marriage children
how to raise them how to talk to them
how to punish all of that it is in our
religion not you don't have to go get a
PhD in some form of a college so that
you can learn how to deal with your
children we know that in our religion
this is the perfectness and the
comprehensive nature of the religion of
Allah stem to deal with the neighbor to
deal with ourselves to deal with the
strangers to deal with the enemies
everything of that we have within the
religion of Islam we need to have the
knowledge of that first this manage is
not to be known by opinions by
environments what makes sense it comes
from the pure Quran and Sunnah of the
Prophet SAW seller the way it was
practiced at the time of the Prophet SAW
settlement le generations of al-islam
and then we need to have the patience to
apply apply it when you don't see the
benefit of it and that's what patients
is if you see the benefit of it then
what what's religion in it you have to
do it because this is what Allah Hannah
Tyler wants from you so you do it even
if you don't see the
at of it like the mother of moosa when
she throw her son musa in the river
moses moses did she know the benefit of
it no she was just submitting to the
orders of Allah the same thing unless we
submit ourselves such in such a way then
the outcome definitely will be good but
we need to have that submission to the
creator of the heavens on you thank you
once again may God Almighty the creator
of the heavens are a lot of awards you
for being with us oh yeah and another
episode of the Dean show we hope that
you got to benefit what led us to submit
ourselves entirely to the one God is
everything that is needed for a human
being to know that this is indeed from
the crater that have is in the earth is
in the verbatim word of God the Quran
it's there it's there all you have to do
is want it the treasure is there you got
the treasure map now you gotta follow it
you've got to live it learn it and come
back here every week to the Dean show
where we talk to qualified people who
can teach us because we get we need
teachers and every field and this is the
most important thing that we need to
learn and then implement and live so we
can be successful not only in this life
but also in the hereafter because we
want to get to paradise because this
life is short you can die at any time so
we hope sincerely that you make dua for
us and you continue striving with
patience to do good in this life and in
the hereafter and we'll see you next
time here on the Dean show until then
peace be unto you
he created the universe to him belong
the heavens and me'll l11 he is the
first he's the phone numbers he sent his
messengers to all his creatures on the
grave danger Oh worshiping other than
Allah there is none greater than create